Chúng tôi không biết trong chuyên thân Washington mà đầu tưởng ngày 20 năm 2020,
tưởng ít Sora Benjamin này tăng cho hong dự kiến sẽ chính tưởng thống Mỹ đoàn trăm một kế hoạch cách trên mới,
nhằm đối phó y ram, đời NBC sẽ lời các quảm chức giống tên chú biến,
Israel đang ngày càng lo ngại, Iran đang mở giống nâng sẵn xuất tên lỗi đa đạo sau của chính kiểu sài mười hai ngày,
dựa hai bên hồi tháng sấu, ngoài ra chào viết cũng quan hại về cả nâng,
se ram nối lại có họ đợp làm sấu, và đi trong phân phổ chứng chính thạp nhân.
Tuy nhiên, giới chữ Israel hiện chưa sắc nhận thông tin này.
Mui cơ xung đồ Israel Iran, tại Bung Phát, được nhiều phương tỉnh chuyên thông của tế để cập trong thời gian cần đây.
Theo một số phần thách, Israel cho sang có cơ tập tế của tháng sấu chưa đặt một tiêu làm tên để chính chính thạp nhìn ý ram trong xài hạc.
Bây giờ đoàn, Iran nhiều lần thẳng định, chú chính thạp nhân mang của bếc hoạm mình,
và bằng bỏ các cáu bộ tự Israel,
tên Iran cạnh mong sẽ đắp chả nếu chú quyền bản ninh cua ra bị sập pháp.